Hey guys, it's Joel, and you're listening to the Taproot Therapy Collective Podcast. Today's article is about the birth of architecture. So I was recently in Spain, I put off travel, um, like the plague, uh, well, not really travel, but vacation time. Um, cause I kind of like what I do. Uh, and it's also more work to leave and come back than it is to not leave. So I don't leave much. And, uh, this was like a trip that had been kicked down the road four years due to two COVIDs and, uh, healthcare emergencies and different things. So we kind of had to do it or lose it. And, um, when I was in, uh, Spain, I drove out to the Dolmen Dominga, which no one else in my, uh, party had any interest in seeing, uh, which is a Neolithic Dolmen. And I took my daughter.
大家好，我是乔尔，你们现在收听的是 Taproot Therapy Collective 播客。今天的文章主题是建筑的诞生。我最近去了西班牙，我一直像躲避瘟疫一样推迟旅行，嗯，其实不是旅行，而是休假。嗯，因为我挺喜欢我的工作。而且，离开再回来比不离开要麻烦得多。所以我很少离开。嗯，这次旅行因为两次新冠疫情、医疗紧急情况和其他各种原因，已经被推迟了四年。所以我们不得不去，否则就作废了。嗯，当我在西班牙的时候，我开车去了多明加石棚墓（Dolmen Dominga），我同行的其他人对参观这个新石器时代的石棚墓毫无兴趣，所以我带上了我的女儿。
And so I was thinking about that. I was going to talk about that um my daughter violet uh is one of my favorite things she really loves uh adventure time which is this tv show that deals a whole lot with uh like fart jokes and then like mythology and western esoteric magic and if you've got a kid and you've got to get up um at i don't know, like 5 or 6 in the morning. Don't watch Baby Bum. Watch Adventure Time. Like the baby finger, baby finger, where are you? You're not going to get anything out of that but a migraine.
我一直在思考这件事。我本来想谈谈这件事，嗯，我的女儿维奥莱特是我最喜欢的人之一，她真的很喜欢《探险活宝》（Adventure Time），这是一部涉及很多屁话笑话，然后又涉及神话和西方神秘魔法的电视节目。如果你有孩子，而且你必须在，我不知道，比如早上5点或6点起床。别看《Baby Bum》。看《探险活宝》。就像“Baby finger, baby finger, where are you?”，你除了偏头痛什么也得不到。
But Adventure Time, which I don't know, maybe one day I'll write an article about that one because I really love that show. But I wasn't expecting to like it as much as I did, and it's something that we share. But The Dolmen really looked a lot like something out of the show adventure time, you know, Violet loves mythology. She loves creepy tombs. She loves the idea of like long dead empires and the princess Violet stories. I tell her at night, there's always like ancient civilizations. They're guessing about, um, you know, what, what they did or why they did something, but they don't quite know. She's sort of interested in those limits of knowledge. And so she thought this thing was
但《探险活宝》，我不知道，也许有一天我会写一篇关于它的文章，因为我真的很喜欢这部剧。我没想到我会这么喜欢它，这是我们共同的爱好。但那个石棚墓看起来真的很像《探险活宝》里的东西，你知道，维奥莱特喜欢神话。她喜欢阴森的墓穴。她喜欢关于早已灭绝的帝国和公主维奥莱特的故事。我晚上给她讲故事时，总会有古代文明。他们在猜测，嗯，你知道，他们做了什么，或者为什么做某事，但他们并不完全确定。她对这些知识的局限性很感兴趣。所以她觉得这个东西
really cool because it is a Dolman as a portal tomb, um, from the megalithic period where people were making giant things out of stone. This one was a lot older than most of the other ones. Like I've been to Stonehenge and other places um and this one was about 6 000 years old which is kind of um you wouldn't i guess i didn't expect one of the older ones to be bigger you would think that architecture you know would have moved um uh slowly or progressively you know you start out building small things maybe were small things and we just don't have them. But one of the oldest domes that we have, the most impressive, the most impressive is, um, it was one of the biggest. Uh, so that means that the giant, you know, eight, nine ton rocks that people had to slowly carve out of a mountain and then,
非常酷，因为它是一个石棚墓，是一个来自巨石时代的门户墓，当时人们用石头建造巨大的东西。这个比大多数其他的都要古老得多。比如我去过巨石阵和其他地方，嗯，这个大约有6000年的历史，这有点，嗯，我想我没想到其中一个更古老的会更大，你会认为建筑，你知道，会缓慢或渐进地发展，你知道，你从建造小东西开始，也许当时有小东西，只是我们没有保留下来。但我们拥有的最古老的圆顶建筑之一，最令人印象深刻的，嗯，它是最大的之一。所以这意味着那些巨大的，你知道，八、九吨重的岩石，人们必须从山上慢慢雕刻出来，然后，
you know, move somehow without metal tools, um, without, uh, modern ropes that probably had some kind of rope we're pretty wild and so violet going into this thing and touching these you know giant stones and like feeling it was a really neat thing. And what, uh, is sort of interesting is the Dolmen Dominga. It, uh, doesn't face, uh, the summer solstice like a lot of them do. Um, it faces the winter solstice and it does that so that it can face this mountain that looks like a face. And it looks a whole lot like a face. It's not like you kind of have to squint to see it. Like the mountain even has like a face and it looks a whole lot like a face it's like you kind of have to squint to see it like the mountain even has like an adam's apple there's a picture of it on
你知道，在没有金属工具的情况下以某种方式移动它们，嗯，没有现代绳索，可能有一些绳子，这真的很疯狂。所以维奥莱特走进这个东西，触摸这些，你知道，巨大的石头，感觉这真是一件很棒的事情。而且，嗯，有点意思的是多明加石棚墓。它，嗯，不像很多石棚墓那样朝向夏至。嗯，它朝向冬至，这样做是为了面对那座看起来像人脸的山。它看起来真的很像一张脸。不是那种你需要眯着眼睛才能看出来的。就像那座山甚至有一张脸，它看起来真的很像一张脸，就像你得眯着眼睛才能看出来，那座山甚至有一个喉结，博客上有一张照片，
the blog if you want to check it out but it looks like um like a giant is like sleeping underground and uh it's laying in the ground which another that's like another thing that you would find out of adventure time and so you know the thing about prehistory is we really, we can't know anything about it because, um, it is before written, you know, history is birthed with the invention of writing. And so before that, there is no writing, at least not writing that we can read, you know, there probably were picture symbols, like other things that were, you know, proto writingwriting, but not that we have and not that anyone who was a linguist, modern linguist, would consider a language really. And so a lot of that, you know, everything that
如果你想看看的话，但它看起来像，嗯，像一个巨人在地下睡觉，嗯，它躺在地上，这也是你在《探险活宝》里会发现的另一件事。所以你知道，关于史前史的事情是，我们真的，我们对它一无所知，因为，嗯，它是在文字出现之前，你知道，历史是随着文字的发明而诞生的。所以在那之前，没有文字，至少没有我们能读懂的文字，你知道，可能有一些图画符号，像其他东西，你知道，原始文字，但我们没有，而且没有任何现代语言学家会认为那是真正的语言。所以很多，你知道，我们所知道的一切都只是猜测，但你可以猜测，这些去伊比利亚并长期留在那里的人，就像去过西班牙之后，你就能明白他们为什么会留下来，因为西班牙的一切，嗯，都芬芳且可食用。这太狂野了。比如，嗯，你知道，他们到那里时显然有很多橄榄，我们认为他们可能花了很长时间才弄清楚如何使用它们。那可能不是他们留下的原因。那是他们留下的副产品。但我去徒步旅行看了一些更新的新石器时代文字。因为很多遗址，比如，没有大门之类的东西。
we know is just kind of a guess, but you could guess that these people who go to Iberia and then stay in Iberia for a really long time, which like after having been to Spain, you kind of see why they would stay because like everything in Spain, um, was like fragrant and edible. It was wild. Like, um, you know, there are obviously a lot of olives when they got there, which we think that it probably took them a long time to figure out how to use them. That's probably not why they stayed. That was a byproduct of them staying. But I went on a hike to see some other Neolithic writing that was a lot newer. Because a lot of the sites, like, there's no, like, gate or anything.
你只需要找到一个GPS点，徒步穿过某人的土地，走到一个洞穴，然后去看看。再说一次，博客上有照片。我进去的一个洞穴里有一个用氧化铁做的小人，但是，嗯，真的很小。我的意思是，洞穴这个词用得太慷慨了。它更像是一个洞，但是，嗯，在徒步旅行时，你知道，我摘了粉红胡椒浆果，我想那不是当地的东西，但到处都是茴香，闻起来棒极了。那天晚上吃牛排时，我把一些胡椒浆果放进了口袋。在徒步旅行中，我得到了一些野蒜。它可能不是野生的。它可能是因为100年前那里有一所房子之类的东西而生长的。
You just find a GPS point, you hike across somebody's land, you go to, like, a cave, and you go see it. Again. There's a picture of that on the blog. There's a little guy made out of iron oxide that was inside of a cave that I went into, but, um, real small. I mean, cave is a general, their cave is generous. It was more like a hole, but, um, like on the hike, you know, I picked pink pepper berries, which I guess that's not a local thing, but there was these just fennel everywhere that just smelled wonderful. Having a steak that night, I put some of the pepper berries in my pocket. On the hike, I got some of the wild garlic. It probably wasn't wild. It probably was growing because there had been a house there 100 years ago or something.
我徒步穿过了曾经可能是，嗯，宅基地的地方。嗯，然后，嗯，你知道，我们烤了一些茴香球，嗯，大蒜，嗯，我发现了野鼠尾草。嗯，这只是一个干燥的，嗯，气候，只有那种沙质土壤，嗯，长不出太多东西，但长出来的东西通常可以吃，而且你可以看得非常远。这是一个不错的地方。你可以明白为什么他们待了足够长的时间来弄清楚像建筑这样的东西，这可能花了很长时间才能弄清楚怎么做。所以这个墓，如果你不熟悉的话，石棚墓是门户墓。所以它是这样的，你得到这些岩石，你知道，这个定居点的一些石头，我想最大的顶石大约有180吨，这简直太疯狂了。我的意思是，你在谈论人们，你知道，像冰淇淋三明治一样凿出，
I hiked through what was probably, um, the, the homestead at one point. Um, and then, uh, you know, we grilled some of the fennel bulbs, uh, the garlic, um, I found wild sage growing. Um, and it's just like a dry, um, climate with just kind of like sandy soil, um, that not a ton can grow in, but the stuff that grows usually you can eat and you can see really far. It's just a nice place. You could kind of see why they hung out long enough to figure out something like architecture, which probably took a long time to be able to figure out how to do. So this tomb, if you're not familiar, dolmens are portal tombs. So what it is is you get these rocks, you know, some of the ones at this settlement, like the biggest capstone I think was like 180 tons, which is just insane. I mean, you're talking about people, you know, chiseling out an ice cream sandwich style,
形状，不是风格，形状，像一块岩石，基本上，通过凿掉其他所有东西。就像没有办法直接从山上把它切下来一样。你必须移除它周围的山。然后以某种方式滚动它，搬运它，通过土坡把它抬起来，你知道，挖出这些其他的石头，在那里放点东西，拥有这个，你知道，可能是一个相当神圣的空间。我想说，你知道，我听到这些争论，人们说，它们是宗教场所，还是，嗯，像神圣的空间，或者它们是实际使用的，它们被用来传达知识。这就像所有这些，所有这些，就像我们没有学科一样。他们什么都没有。我
shaped, not style, shaped, like piece of rock, basically, by chiseling everything else away. Like there's no way to cut it directly out of the mountain. You have to remove the mountain around it. And then somehow rolling it, carrying it, lifting it up an earthen ramp, you know, digging up these other stones, putting something there and having this, you know, what was probably a pretty sacred space. And to say like, you know, I hear these debates where people are like, are they religious sites or are they, um, like holy spaces or were they practically used for, they used to convey knowledge. And it was like all of it, all of it, like that we didn't have disciplines. They didn't have anything. I
我的意思是，关于建筑的诞生，对我来说最有趣的是，当你深入挖掘并观察那段历史时期时，它就像除了语言之外的第一大技术，它把地球撕裂开来，使我们变得与众不同。而且没有任何东西能恢复到原来的样子。因为在那之前，对吧，在有人搬运这些石头并制造这些东西之前，我的意思是，诚然，这可能需要几代人的时间。它需要前所未有的协调，你有阶级的人可以绘制太阳图，
mean, the thing that is so interesting to me about the birth of architecture right is that like when you dig down and you look at that period of history it is like one of the first biggest technologies other than maybe language that like rends the earth apart and makes us different And nothing can ever be put back the way it was before. Because before that, right, before somebody lugged these stones and made these things, I mean, granted, it took lifetimes to do this, probably. It took coordination that no one had ever seen before, that you had classes of people that could chart the sun,
可以用小石头测量，可以向领导层传达为什么这是巩固人类整体力量和进步的事情，谁可以协调，谁可以，你知道，喂养做这件事的人，而不是去打猎或做其他任何事情。你知道，在那个没有任何剩余物资的时代，这很辛苦。但一旦你做了，你知道，在那之前，人类是什么，就是自然。我的意思是，他们走在自然中，你知道，也许有木屋，我把这些东西支撑起来，但如果那里有一座山，对吧？它就在那里。如果那里有一棵树，它就在那里。世界只是这个
that could measure that with little rocks, that could convey to the leadership why this was something that would entrench the overall power and progress of mankind, who could coordinate, who could, you know, feed the people who were doing this instead of hunting or doing anything else. You know, it was hard work in a time where there wasn't a whole lot of surplus anything. But like once you do that, you know, before that, what humanity is, is nature. I mean, they're walking through nature, you know, maybe there's wood houses that I prop these things up, but if there's a mountain there, right? Like it's there. And if there's a tree there, it's there. And the world is just this
我作为人类遇到的自然事物，我作为人类是其中的一部分，我无法真正将自己与它分开，我无法真正控制它。你知道，这之前的家，你知道，也许你挖一条沟，在上面放木头，但这只是一个暂时的微小改变。这只是一个猜测。我的意思是，没有任何类似的东西能持续下去。我们有，它在欧洲的其他地方确实存在。所以我们知道，你知道，人们可能在那样做，但，而且我不是考古学家，你知道，我上过几门考古课。嗯，但是，我，我们在节目中回到起源，精神病体验、集体潜意识的交集，你知道，精神病和技术，你知道
natural thing that I'm encountering as a human, that I'm a part of as a human, that I can't really separate myself from, that I can't really control. You know, the homes that are before this are, you know, maybe you dig down a trench, you put wood over it, but this is just such a temporary little change. And this is a guess. I mean, nothing like that would have lasted. And we have, it does in other parts of the, of Europe. So we know that, you know, people were probably doing that, but like, and I'm not an archeologist, you know, I had a couple of archeology classes. Um, but the, I, we come back on the show it's on to the origin the intersection of like psychotic experience the collective unconscious you know the psychosis and technology you know
技术进步改变了我们对人类的看法，改变了我们对世界的看法，改变了我们产生幻觉的方式，改变了我们创造和信仰的方式，你知道，改变了宗教，这些东西是如此，你知道，交织在一起，以一种我们可以看到但无法直接理解的方式，你知道，我们只能直觉地理解，也许这就是我为什么那么喜欢它，当你有一个人见过这些基本上是木头和泥土的结构，地球会收回它，是的，你支撑起一个棚子，但你并不重要。然后突然之间，你看到在你的社会中心有一个圆顶的东西，可以与天堂交流，可以预测太阳要做什么，
technological progress changes what we view as human changes what we view as the world changes the way that we hallucinate changes the way that we create and believe you know changes religion and that these things are like so you know intertwined together in a way that we can see but we can't directly understand you know we can only intuitively understand that maybe that's why i like that so much and when you have somebody who has seen these structures that are basically wood and mud and the earth is going to reclaim it yeah you propped up a lean-to, but you don't really matter. And then all of a sudden, you see in the center of your society that there is a domed thing that can communicate with the heavens, that can predict what the sun is going to do,
因为在太阳投下最长阴影的那一天，那个阴影一直延伸到这个东西的门口，它被制造成看起来像自然，就像我们当时甚至无法构想摩天大楼或任何与自然太不同的东西，我们必须在这些圆形的、这些像尖头石头两侧放上泥土，顶部平坦，使它们更自然，使它们更有机，使它们更像一个圆顶，现在所有这些东西两侧都有泥土支撑，上面可能有草和树，嗯，也许不是树，嗯，但像草和东西在上面生长，动物在上面走过，但中间有一个洞，一直通向墓室，在最里面有骨头，有祖先，
because on the day that the sun casts its longest shadow that shadow reaches all the way through the doorway of this thing that is sort of made to look like nature like we couldn't even conceive of a skyscraper or anything that was like Too different from nature at that point we had to put earth on either side of these rounded of these like pointed stones with a flat top to make them more natural to make them more organic to make them more of a dome now all of these things had earth propped up on both sides that probably had grass and trees and um maybe not trees um but like grass and things growing on it and animals walking over it but there was a hole in the middle that went all the way back to a tomb space and at the very back there were bones and there were ancestors there
有被放在那里的人，他们永远留在了那里，在最长的一天，冬至，这个东西可以预测，或者是由能预测星星的人制造的。当它投下最长的光线时，当它最接近地平线时，光线会照进来，因为精确的测量，阳光会触碰到骨头
were people who were put in there who stayed there forever and on the longest day the solstice this thing could predict or was made by people who could predict the stars The light would shine when it's casting its longest ray, when it's closest down to that horizon, all the way back because of the precise measurement so that the sunlight would touch the bones
在石棚墓的后面，架起这座桥，你知道，再说一次，一切都是假设。一切都是猜测。我们不知道。让他们永生。把他们的灵魂带到来世，你知道，提醒他们，他们与一个更大的世界保持着联系。但当那个圆顶被制造出来时，当有人雕刻
that were in the back of the dolmen, making this bridge that, you know, again, everything is a supposition. Everything is a guess. We don't know. Made them immortal. Took their soul to the afterlife, you know, reminded them that they were in communication with a bigger world. But when that dome was made, when somebody carved
这个东西是用岩石做的，他们看着它，他们觉得，这不会消失。这比我大。这不是泥土和棍子。而且，你知道，有这些东西的城市。有，你知道，长屋，但它们的无常是当你看到石棚墓时，你知道世界已经不同了，自然空间已经被永远切割和分叉成人类声称的空间，我部落声称的空间，以及其他所有东西。如果你看看像伊利亚德·米尔恰（Iliade Mercha）这样的人，我们经常谈论的比较宗教学者，
this thing out of rock that they could look at and they were like, this isn't going away. This is bigger than me. This isn't mud and sticks. And, you know, there were cities of these things. There were, you know, long houses and, but the impermanence of them was something that when you saw a Dolman, you knew that the world was different, that the, the natural space had been forever cut and bifurcated into mankind's claimed space, my tribe's claimed space, and the rest of everything else. If you look at somebody like Iliade Mercha, the comparative religion guy that we talk about a lot,
他研究了澳大利亚的原住民，说宗教是关于创造一个世界中心，你的存在围绕着它旋转，其他一切都不是，其他一切都是混乱，他研究了原住民，他们会有，我想它叫Genza，但它有一个更长的名字，但它要么是这个装饰过的石头或棍子，他们会把它放在他们露营的中间，有时如果是棍子版本，它会支撑他们睡觉的帐篷，他们有火在下面，当它在早上倒下时，它会告诉他们
who studied the aboriginals in Australia and said that religion was about making a center of the world that your existence revolved around, and everything else was not that everything else was chaos and he studied the aborigines that would have i think it's called a genza but it was like uh there's a longer name for it too but it would be either this decorated rock or stick and they'd put it in the middle of where they camped and sometimes if it was the stick version it would hold up the tent that they slept under that they had this the fire under and when it fell in the morning it would tell them where
去哪里，这个Genza或这个仪式石器就像澳大利亚这个游牧部落的中心，但如果你看看像那样做比较宗教学的人，他们明白，你知道，因为这种建筑的发明把地球裂成了两半，它们并不整齐。它们是人类可以在地球上创造的东西。我正在看一个在我死后还会存在的东西。不是一个故事，不是一幅可能会被擦掉的画，不是一个可能会被烧毁的村庄。我正在看一块180吨重的石头，它只是构成这座建筑的其他许多100吨重石头的一部分。从我作为新石器时代人的角度来看，它将永远在那里。我刚刚变得像个神。而且，你知道，这对心理学的影响，这对
to go and this Ginza or this ritual stone object was like the center of this nomadic tribe in Australia but if you look at somebody who's doing comparative religion like that, they get it, you know, because this invention of architecture cracked the earth into two halves that weren't neat. They were what mankind could create on the earth. And I'm looking at something that will be around when I die. Not a story, not a painting that might get erased, not a village that may get burned. I'm looking at 180 ton stone that's just one part of a whole lot of other 100 ton stones making this building. And from my perspective as a Neolithic person, that is going to be there forever. I just became like a god. And, you know, the effect that that would have on psychology, the effect that that would have on
你在部落中的身份的影响，嗯，你只是知道这一刻是如何突然将你与自然分开，几乎就像把你从像动物一样的子宫中拉出来，变成另一种意识到你的范围和自我的东西，以一种我们在创造出这样的东西之前无法做到的方式。我们做不到。而现在我们做到了。我要读一首诗。这是华莱士·史蒂文斯（Wallace Stevens）的《坛之轶事》（The Anecdote of the Jar）。
your identity within a tribe, um, you just know how this moment all of a sudden separates you from nature and, and almost like pulls you out of the womb of being like an animal to being something else that's aware of your scope and yourself in a way that we couldn't before we could create something like that. We couldn't be. And now we are. And I'm going to read a poem. This is Wallace Stevens. The Anecdote of the Jar.
我在田纳西州放了一个坛子。它圆圆地立在山上。它使邋遢的荒野环绕着那座山。荒野升起向它靠拢。不再狂野，坛子在地上是圆的，高大且有气势，它统治了一切，坛子是灰色的、光秃秃的，它不像田纳西的其他任何东西那样给予鸟儿或灌木。你知道像华莱士这样的现代主义者，华莱士·史蒂文斯试图在那里表达的是，当你把一个不自然的东西带入一个自然空间时，突然之间一切都不自然了，因为自然现在只是与这个东西相比。现在荒野
I placed a jar in Tennessee. And round it was upon a hill. It made the slovenly wilderness surround that hill. The wilderness rose up to it. Andled around no longer wild the jar was round upon the ground and tall and of a port and air and it took dominion everywhere the jar was gray and bare and it did not give of bird or bush like nothing else in tenn You know what a modernist like Wallace is trying to, what Wallace Stevens is trying to say there is like that when you take a unnatural thing into a natural space, all of a sudden everything is unnatural because nature is now only in comparison to this thing. Now the wilderness
向它升起。荒野不仅仅是升起。它不仅仅是在那里。坛子正在反射自然，自然正在与这个被放在那里的坛子对话。嗯，他们实际上让我读了这个。嗯，它在我在斯瓦尼（Swanee）的代数教科书的前面，那本书叫，不，微积分，对不起，不是代数。它叫《微积分，一门文科》。它就像关于，你知道，数学中的一切都是一系列参考点，就像一个没有其他真正数字的数字并没有什么意义。只有当你把数字带入关系时，它们才存在。但这是一种非常文科的做法。嗯，所以，你知道，在建筑之前，世界是一个未分割的、无缝的实体，没有明确的界限，你知道，
raises up to it. The wilderness doesn't just rise. It isn't just there. The jar is reflecting nature and nature is in conversation with this jar that has been put there. Um, they actually made me read this. Uh, it was in the front of my algebra textbook at Swanee, which was called, no calculus, I'm sorry, not algebra. It was called calculus, a liberal art. And it was like about how, you know, everything in math is a series of reference points, like one number without other really numbers doesn't really mean anything. It's only when you bring numbers into relationship to do they exist. But it's a very liberal arts thing to do. Um, and so, you know, before architecture, the world was this undivided, seamless entity with no clear boundaries between, you know,
人类和自然环境。而现在人们感到不朽，石棚墓和其他建筑结构的建造粉碎了这种统一的感知。它创造了这个新的范式，人类会，你知道，积极地塑造和声称地球的一部分，它改变了国家，你知道，所有权的概念，你知道，建立了国家，这种对空间的声称和在其上竖立结构代表了一种深刻的心理转变，因为人类开始主张他们的代理权和对周围环境的控制。我的意思是，你必须在那里待上一千年，才会想到开始建造那些能建造这些结构的结构，即能够建造石棚墓的社会、政治和金融工具。
human and natural environment. And now men feel immortal and the construction of dolmens and other architectural structures shattered this unified perception. And it created this new paradigm where humans would, you you know actively shape and claim portions of the earth it changed nations you know notions of ownership you know built nations and this claiming of space and erecting structures upon it represented a profound psychological shift as humans began to assert their agency and control over their surroundings. I mean, you had to be there for a thousand years before it occurs to you to start even building the structures that can build these structures, the social and political and financial tools to be able to build a dolmen.
当你看看这对游牧部落的所有权概念会有什么影响时。比如，当然，这片土地属于它。我正在使用它。我已经用了几代人了。这些人正在耕种。如果我建造一个石棚墓，我将永远在这里。它可以预测太阳。它可以预测月亮，那些永恒的东西。那种裂痕，我认为，有这些持久的影响。而这对宗教的影响可能非常深远。
And when you look at what that would do to a nomadic tribe's conception of ownership. Like, sure, this land's on it. I'm using it. I've used it for a couple generations. These people are farming. If I build a dolmen, I will be here forever. It can predict the sun. It can predict the moon, things that are eternal. That rift, I think, has these long-lasting implications. And the impact of that on religion was probably very profound.
你知道，你有这种人造空间的创造，比如石棚墓，它提供了人类代理权和塑造世界能力的具体体现。现在，世界不是我必须与之互动的东西。它是某种我，我物种余生对话的其余部分将是关于我能对它做什么。坛之轶事。罗伯特·波格·哈里森（Robert Pogue Harrison）是我喜欢的一位作家。他写了《死者的统治》（Dominion of the Dead），这可能是他最好的书，至少是我读过的最好的书。我还没读过《Juvenessence》和一些新的。但是，你知道，他在那本书中探索了建筑。他谈到了建筑如何标志着人类心理的这种转变。你知道，在建筑之前，人类生活在一个自然世界中，自然环境占主导地位，死亡是一个永远存在的现实。然后建筑的发明允许人类在面对
You know, you have this creation of man-made spaces like dolmens that provide this tangible manifestation of human agency and the ability to shape the world. Now, the world is not something that I have to interact with. It is something that I, the rest of my conversation for the rest of my species existence will be about what I can do to it. Anecdote of the jar. And Robert Pogue Harrison is an author I like. He wrote Dominion of the Dead, which is probably his best book, at least the best book that I've ever read. I haven't read Juvenessence and some of the new ones. But, you know, he explores architecture in that book. And he talks about how architecture marks this shift in human psychology. You know, before architecture, humans lived in a natural world where the natural environment was dominant and death was this ever-present reality. And then the invention of architecture allowed humans to create a sense of permanence and stability in the face of the
生命的短暂本质时创造一种持久感和稳定性。这不仅仅是因为建筑在我死后还会存在，对吧？这是因为建筑是我文化的一部分，提醒我，当我还是个孩子，来到这个世界时，我不是看着自然世界说我是其中的一部分。我看着科林斯柱说我是帝国的一部分。我看着爱奥尼柱说我是雅典人。我在两岁时看着某种在我出生前一百年就在这里的东西。这改变了我对自己是什么、我能成为什么、人类是什么、上帝是什么的看法，以一种巨大的方式，它不精确或准确，但它是深刻的，你知道，就像
transient nature of life. And that isn't just because the building will be around after I die, right? It is because the building is something that is part of my culture and reminding me when I'm a child and I come into the world, I'm not looking at the natural world and saying I'm a part of that. I'm looking at a Corinthian column and saying I'm part of an empire. I'm looking at an Ionic column and saying I'm an Athenian. I'm looking at something when I'm two that was here a hundred years before I was born. And that changes the way that I think of what I am and what I can be and what humanity is and what God is and this huge way that isn't precise or exact but it is profound and you know like
哈里森谈到，你知道，建筑的那个想法，我喜欢《死者的统治》，因为它不仅研究得非常详尽且合理，而且它的所有主要观点都像是完全推测性的，但对我来说它们并不觉得牵强。其中一个观点是，建筑的发明可能发明了来世的概念，因为因为在那之前，我只是发现自己在这个巨大的球体上，我永远无法探索它，我永远无法理解它，其中一些仍然是真的。你知道，我永远无法真正改变它。然后突然之间，我找到了我偶然发现的这个东西，我可以让它永远不同。所以我为什么要死？对吧？为什么
Harrison talks about how you know that idea of architecture and I love the dominion of the dead because it's one incredibly well researched and plausible but two all of its main points are like completely speculative but they don't feel like reaches to me one of those points is that the invention of architecture probably invented the notion of an afterlife because because before i just found myself on this giant ball and i could never explore it i could never understand it some of this is still true. You know, I could never really change it. And then all of a sudden I get to find this thing that I came upon and I get to make it different forever. So why do I have to die? Right? Why do
我必须死？如果我能做一些不朽的事情，也许我应该是不朽的。你知道，我不是说建筑真的创造了来世。我是说它让我们意识到，来世是我们能够思考到足以在精神和文化上进行推测的东西。哈里森，就像，还有一部分，我想我在不同的事情中用过几次，但他谈到，就像你可以对直觉主义者做的最令人不安的事情之一是，向他们展示，比如，一个巨大的正在崩塌的帝国建筑，上面爬满了常春藤。因为那时他们意识到他们会死。建筑不仅给了我们来世的想法，它也，你在看，我看着
I have to die? If I can do something that is immortal, maybe I should be immortal. You know, I'm not saying that architecture actually created an afterlife. I'm saying that it made us realize that an afterlife was something that we could think about enough to speculate spiritually and culturally. Harrison, like, there's also, there's a chunk that I think I've used it a couple times in different things, but he talks about how like one of the most unsettling things that you can do to an intuitive is, like, show them, like, a giant crumbling empire building that's just, like, overrun with ivy. Because then they realize that they die. Not only does architecture give us an idea for an afterlife, it also,'re looking at and i definitely have this when i look
废墟时绝对有这种感觉，我的意思是维奥莱特和我分享这一点，你知道，嗯，我想这就是为什么我想让她看石棚墓，当你看到废墟，意识到你是多么渺小，你有多么不重要，你将如何死去，即使你知道你会死，你知道，你走过常春藤覆盖的，嗯，你知道，柱子和倒塌的城市，你真的感受到了死亡，嗯，作为一个很难感受到的现实，嗯，你知道，以其他方式。当你走出多明加石棚墓时，这座东西面对的山，有我告诉你的那张看起来像沉睡巨人的脸。而且，你知道，也许他们认为那是一个死去的上帝。也许他们认为那是一个真正的巨人。也许他们只是认为它是故事中使用的某种象征。
at ruins i mean violet shares this you know um with me i think that's why i wanted her to see the dolman like when you see ruins and you realize how small you are and how little you matter and how much you will die in a way that even if you know you're going to die, you know, you walk through Ivy colored, um, you know, columns and cities that are toppled and you really feel death, um, as a reality that is hard to feel, uh, you know, otherwise. And the mountain that this thing faces when you walk out of the Dolmen Dominga, there is that face that I told you about that looks like a sleeping giant. And, you know, maybe they thought it was a dead god. Maybe they thought it was an actual giant. Maybe they just thought that it was symbolic of something that was used in story.
再说一次，史前史，我们不知道。但那座山上到处都是许多小的，你知道，铭文、饰品和东西。所以他们认为那可能是一个相当神圣的地方，因为人们在那里待的时间足够长，以至于丢下东西、在东西上写字等等。但是，你知道，所有这些东西，你进入了一个叫考古天文学的领域。那个领域里的很多人完全是怪人。而其他人则是非常严肃的人类学家，你知道，试图通过，你知道，从岩石上提取酸并观察人们吃了什么等等来确定他们的发现日期。有些对我来说太细致了，有些太玄乎了。奇幻。但他们正在尝试做数学，看看，
Again, prehistory, like we don't know. But there was lots of little, you know, inscriptions and trinkets and things found all over that mountain. So they think that that probably was a pretty holy place because people were hanging out there enough to drop stuff and write on stuff and what all. But, you know, all of these things, you get into something called archaeoastrology. And a lot of the people in that space are just total cranks. And the other ones are like very serious anthropologists, you know, trying to date their findings by, you know, pulling acid off of rocks and seeing what people ate and whatnot. Some of it gets too granular for me, some of it gets too woo-woo. Fantastical. But they're trying to do math to see like,
这些东西与什么对齐，你知道，在宇宙中？它们与什么对齐，比如移动的天体和星星？然后根据这些人的技术能力，以及基于这些东西的宗教能力进行猜测。所以这很有趣。你知道，我听到很多人说，好吧，你不能真正知道巨石阵是否与太阳有任何关系，因为你可能只是偏离了两英寸。然后这意味着整个，你知道，其他人写的论文，你知道，不起作用，数学不起作用。就像，是的，可能，你知道，弄错它可能很容易。但我同时也认为，说他们只是无缘无故地做这件事，他们对任何形式的天文运动都没有知识，也没有宗教，这完全是疯狂的。我也听到人们说那篇论文，就像我们永远无法知道，所以我们不应该去想它，我不知道
what do these things line up with, you know, in the cosmos? What do they line up with, like celestial bodies moving and stars? And then make guesses based on what these people, what their technological ability was and then what their religious capacity was based on those things. And so that's interesting. You know, I've heard a lot of people say, well, you can't really know that even Stonehenge has anything to do with the sun because you could just be off by two inches. And then that would mean the whole, you know, paper this other guy wrote doesn't, you know, doesn't work the math and it doesn't work. And like, yeah, probably like it's probably very easy to get that wrong. But I also think that it's completely crazy to say like they just did it for no reason and they had no knowledge of any kind of astrological movements and no religion. I've also heard people say that paper of like we can never know so we shouldn't think about it and I don't know that
我也买账。另一件事是这些东西可能被涂过漆。还剩下两个石棚墓，因为记住这些东西，你知道，有2000年历史，至少，通常更古老，嗯，所以东西不会持续，你知道，就像我去的那个，前两块石头可能完全不见了，我们可以看到它们是在哪里被凿出来的，但有人可能只是把它们拖走去建一座城堡或中世纪时期的什么东西，或者一口井，我的意思是，一些无聊的东西，你知道，有中世纪时期制作的雕刻。多明加石棚墓的最里面有一口井，这很奇怪。你不会经常看到那个。
I buy that either. And the other thing is these things were probably painted. There's two dolmens left because remember these things are like you know 2 000 years old like at least and usually way older um so just things don't last you know like the one that i went to the first two stones are probably completely missing we can see where they were carved out but somebody probably just hauled them off to build a castle or something in the medieval period or a well i mean something boring um you know there's carvings that were made in the medieval period or a well. I mean, something boring. You know, there's carvings that were made in the medieval period. The Dolmen Dominga has a well in the very back of it, which is weird. You don't see that much.
但他们钻了一个非常整齐的洞，大约有雨水渠盖那么大，你知道，穿过20米厚的基岩，这很难，用，你知道，其他岩石或磨尖的鹿角碎片，这令人难以置信，但你知道，那完全被垃圾填满了，垃圾就像很多是中世纪、罗马，然后比那更现代，所以他们认为只是在几个时代，有人试图寻宝，你知道，他们就像，会有黄金之类的，你知道，他们探索了，谁知道他们发现了什么，你知道，他们就像，会有黄金之类的，你知道，他们探索了，谁知道他们发现了什么。你知道，这不是一个冶金文化，那里可能没有多少黄金。
But they drilled a very neat hole about the size of a storm drain cover, you know, 20 meters through bedrock, which is hard, with, you know, either other rocks or pieces of deer antler that were sharpened, which is unbelievable but you know that was completely filled in with just junk and the junk was like a lot of it was like medieval roman and then like much more modern than that so they think that just during several eras somebody tried to treasure hunt you know they're like they'll be gold or whatever you know they explored who knows what they found, you know, they're like, there'll be gold or whatever, you know, they explored, who knows what they found. You know, this wasn't a metallurgic culture, there probably wasn't a lot of gold there.
但我们所知道的是，葡萄牙还剩下两个石棚墓，你仍然可以看到油漆。因为这些东西可能被涂过漆。这是非常粗糙的岩石。这种岩石看起来像，我不是地质学家，但它看起来像当你浇筑混凝土并将其与鹅卵石混合，其他岩石的碎片像从岩石中突出来一样。所以它非常粗糙。所以它必须被涂漆，你知道，你不能，在上面做壁画会很难。但我们拥有的画作就像蜿蜒的线条，很多几何图案，你知道，菱形、正方形，
But what we do know, there's two dolmens left in Portugal where you can still see the paint. Because these things were probably painted. This is very rough rock. It's the kind of rock that looks like, I'm not a geologist, but it looks like when you pour concrete and mix it with pebbles and the pieces of other rock are like sticking out of the rock. So it's like very rough. So it has to be painted, you know, you can't, it'd be hard to do a fresco on. But the paintings that we have are like squiggly lines, a lot of geometric patterns, you know, diamonds, squares,
你在其他某种前工业文化中看到的东西。我们不知道它们意味着什么。它们看起来不像洞穴和其他地方的许多文字。它们看起来像人或水牛，或者某种万物有灵的萨满精神，那里有人和动物的融合。你在石棚墓里看不到那个。你只看到这些本应影响某种心理的东西的图案，对我来说有趣的是，就像是的，这在某种程度上是人类的诞生，突然之间我们
the things you see in other sort of pre-industrial cultures. And we don't know what they mean. They don't really look like a lot of the writings in caves and different things. They look like people or buffalo or sort of animistic shaman spirits where there's a fusion of a man and an animal. You don't see that in the dolmens. You just see these patterns that were supposed to affect some kind of psychological thing and what's interesting to me is that like yes this sort of was this birth of human humanity where all of a sudden we were
意识到我们活着并且与自然分离，因为我们可以做一些永远不会消失的事情，你知道，那会产生我们能想象到的最大影响，你知道，一旦我们看到它，但也，嗯，所以是的，从那个意义上说是诞生，但然后可能就像这些东西被用于某种仪式来模拟出生，因为你在这个令人难以置信的黑暗空间里，在山里的黑暗中，然后你沿着一条长长的隧道从一个巨大的圆洞走出来，所有这些都进入阳光，所以想象一下那种走出来面对满月或面对太阳的效果，你知道，走向太阳，你知道，也许他们对国王或萨满那样做，我们不知道，但无论它是什么，结合声音和
realizing we were alive and separate from nature because we could do something that would never go away you know that would have the biggest impact that we could imagine you know once we see it but also um so yeah it's the birth in that sense but then probably like these things were used in some kind of ritual to simulate a birth because you are in this incredibly dark space that's inside of a mountain in the darkness and then you go down a long tunnel from a giant round hole and all of them into sunlight so imagine the effect of that coming out and facing the full moon or facing the sun you know walking towards the sun you know maybe they did that to kings or shamans something we don't know but whatever it was combined with sound and
几何图案，我的意思是，这就像最刺激的体验，嗯，你可能在这个时代拥有过，没有，你知道，现代仪器和手机，以及我们现在拥有的所有奇观。所以，你知道，回到我们之前谈到的彼得·斯洛特戴克（Peter Sloterdijk），他基本上说，观察人类纪元并理解它们的最好方法，他是一位哲学家，是观察他所称的“人类技术”（anthropotechnics），也就是人们如何制造文化、技术和进步，他们将这些东西融合在一起以创造这些保护空间。斯洛特戴克说，最初有这个原始的球体，你知道，地球，然后我们把它裂开，然后我们制造不同的部落和国家，以及这些国家内的不同政治派别和家庭，是的，我是美国人，但我的人民来自西西里岛，实际上我也是一个
the geometric patterns i mean this would have been like the most stimulating experience um that you probably could have had in this time without, you know, modern instruments and cell phones and all of the spectacle that we have now. So, you know, going back to we talked about like Peter Sloterdijk before, who basically says that the best way to look at, he's a philosopher, to look at the epics of humans and to understand them is to look at something called what he calls anthropotechnics, which is like how people make culture and technology and progress, that they fuse those things together to create these protective spaces. And Sloterdijk says that originally there's this primal sphere you know of the earth and then we crack it and then we make different tribes and nations and different political affiliations within those nations and families and yeah i'm an american but my people came from sicily and really i'm a
西西里人，你知道，它变成了这些球体在竞争。而现在我们失去了真正的意义感，因为我们的身份就像泡沫，而过去它是气泡。所以，你知道，他谈到的球体学，关于创造和居住空间。你知道，把这看作我们制造的第一个，你知道，墓穴，是的，也是像子宫一样的空间。我不知道。关于它我没有太多要说的了。但我确实认为这些东西很有趣，当我们思考它时，我们并不总是以那种方式思考它。特别是当你的考古老师告诉你哪种，你知道，哪种类型的β-酸表明人们在那个地区吃玉米，而不是仅仅思考，嗯，我们历史的重力。嗯，不仅仅是作为人或美国人或什么，而是作为人类，以及改变的心理学，以及心理学现在有多少
sicilian too and you know that it becomes to where these spheres are competing. And right now we've lost our real sense of meaning because our identity is like foam where it used to be bubbles. So that, you know, spherology that he talks about, about creating and inhabiting spaces. You know, think about this as that first, you know, tomb, yes, but also womb-like space that we made. I don't know. I don't have that much more to say about it. But I do think that this stuff is interesting, and when we think about it, we don't always think about it in that way. Especially not when your archaeology teacher is telling you about which you know, which type of beta acid indicates that people like ate corn in the region, instead of just sort of contemplating the nature of the, um, the gravity of our history. Um, not just like as people or Americans or something, but like as humans and the psychology that changed and how much psychology is
在改变，你知道，如果你想谈论最后一段历史移动得有多快，你知道，技术速度每两年翻一番，所有这些，就像，是的，好吧，嗯，但当你没有思考人类学以及这在历史上发生了多少，并试图理解它时，你如何理解、预测并与之互动，你知道，建筑，我认为，是这种试图整理空间并从中创造意义的方式，以一种有用的方式，以及一种正在影响，你知道，心理上和实践上的方式，它允许人类产生影响，这就是建筑，这就是为什么石棚墓如此有趣，我低头看地面，当
changing now you know like that if you want to talk about how well the last history is moving so fast and you know the speed of technology doubles everything every two years and all of that like yeah okay um but how do you understand that and predict that and interact with that when you're not thinking about anthropology and how much this has happened over history and trying to understand that you know architecture i think is this attempt to order space and make meaning out of it in a way that is useful and a way that is affecting you know both psychologically and practically it allows humans to have effect that's what architecture is and that's why dolmen is so interesting i looked down on the ground when
我们在石棚墓时，我注意到维奥莱特正在用灰尘，你知道，泥土地板做一个小房子，她做了一个微小的圆顶东西，然后一旦她完成了，只是因为她很紧张和无聊，她并不是试图复制她所在的结构，然后之后她开始挖出内部，你知道，制造这种圆顶球体，我认为这些东西，就像我们关于孩子，就像他们是这些白纸，而且，你知道，好吧，他们会受到学校或宝可梦或什么的的影响，但实际上就像他们，他们天生就与这些东西有联系，嗯，我们，你知道，失去联系，你知道，我们正在失去联系的文化中不健康的部分，
we were at the dolmen and i noticed that violet was making like a little house out of the dust you know dirt floor and that she had made like a tiny domed thing and that then once she had finished it just because she was nervous and bored she wasn't trying to make a replication of the structure she was in and then afterwards she started to scoop out the inside you know and make this kind of domed sphere and i think these things like we about kids, like they're these blank slates and, you know, well, they're going to get influenced by school or Pokemons or whatever, but really like they're, they're born in touch with these things, um, that we, you know, lose touch, you know, the, the unhealthy parts of culture that we were losing touch with something,
我们在支石墓那里时，我注意到维奥莱特正用灰尘，你知道，泥土地，做成一个小房子的样子。她做了一个微小的圆顶状的东西，一旦做完，仅仅是因为她感到紧张和无聊，她并不是想复制她所处的那个结构。之后她开始挖空内部，你知道，做成这种圆顶球体。我认为关于孩子的事情，就像他们是白纸一样，你知道，好吧，他们会受到学校、宝可梦或其他什么东西的影响，但实际上，他们天生就与这些事物有联系，而我们，你知道，失去了联系，你知道，我们正在失去与文化中那些不健康部分的联系。
not imprinting anything. And I want to keep my kids in touch with these things, this sense of awe and this sense of intellectual humility. I mean, that's why we talk about the limits of what we can't ever know and do know now when I talk to my kids. And many kids are closer to this wellspring of archetypes and imaginative potentials than most adults. You know, a lot of therapy, a lot of healing is trying to reintroduce those things to people. It's trying to get beyond a rational bounded ego structure and get back into what's under it so that you can remember what the ego was for. It's not that we don't need it. It's not that you can live in nirvana. It's that you have to be in touch with something that is bigger than you to know who you are is one of these tensions. And, you know, I think, you know, my,
并没有灌输任何东西。我想让我的孩子们保持与这些事物的联系，保持这种敬畏感和理性的谦逊。我的意思是，这就是为什么我和孩子们交谈时，会谈论我们永远无法知晓的事物与我们现在所知事物的局限性。许多孩子比大多数成年人更接近这种原型和想象潜力的源泉。你知道，很多治疗、很多疗愈过程都是试图将这些东西重新引入人们的生活。它是试图超越理性的、受限的自我结构，回到它之下的东西，这样你就能记住自我的目的是什么。并不是说我们不需要它，也不是说你可以生活在涅槃中。而是说，你必须与某种比你更宏大的事物保持联系，才能知道你是谁，这是这种张力的一部分。而且，你知道，我想，你知道，我的，
my daughter had fear of the dark recently, and I've been taking her to the hammock and like watching the sunset and telling stories and singing songs and like looking at the darkness and talking about my own fear with her. Um, and the kind of things that we see in talking about this idea that the only things that you see in the darkness, um, that scare you are really parts of yourself that you don't know how to deal yet with yet. And that you never really know how to deal with all parts of yourself. Um, but that they are all these things that are a reflection of something that you don't understand that ultimately isn't out there. It's inside of you. Um, and reclaiming those shadows, um, has been something that, um, I've watched empower her, you know, and that, that isn't, uh, you also have to
我女儿最近怕黑，我一直带她去吊床上看日落，讲故事，唱歌，观察黑暗，并和她谈论我自己的恐惧。嗯，我们所看到的事情，以及谈论这个观点，即你在黑暗中看到的唯一让你害怕的东西，实际上是你自己还不知道如何处理的部分。而且你永远无法真正知道如何处理你自己的所有部分。嗯，但它们都是某种你不理解的事物的反映，最终它不在外面，而是在你内心。嗯，重新找回这些阴影，嗯，是我看着她获得力量的过程，你知道，而且那不是，呃，你还必须
prepare your kids for practical fears and realities. You know, we do safety planning too. She also knows about stranger danger and all those risks, especially as a, as a girl. Um, I want to make sure that she knows exactly what she deserves and she's able to advocate for herself. Um, and so I don't think you want to teach kids to ever internalize trauma as something that, um, they need to blame themselves for. But when you're looking at fears that are, um, not from a practical thing, fears that come from creativity, fears that come from looking into the woods and seeing strange shapes, what are those shapes? Those are opportunities to know the soul, um, to know, to know, to teach your kids, to know who they are. And I, I watch her understand this connection
让你的孩子为现实中的恐惧和现实做好准备。你知道，我们也做安全规划。她也知道关于陌生人的危险和所有那些风险，特别作为一个女孩。嗯，我想确保她确切地知道她应得的是什么，并且她能够为自己辩护。嗯，所以我认为你不想教孩子把创伤内化为某种他们需要责怪自己的事情。但是当你面对那些不是来自实际事物的恐惧时，那些来自创造力的恐惧，那些来自看着树林看到奇怪形状的恐惧，那些形状是什么？那些是了解灵魂的机会，嗯，去了解，去教你的孩子，去了解他们是谁。我，我看着她理解这种联系
between, you know, dream and the unknown and unknown and creativity and use the things that scare her in her stories and in her art. Same thing I do with my patients. And same thing that I aspire to keep better touch with myself. And so I guess I'll leave that there. But, you know, a lot of the things that come up at this point and watching a child see how much of herself is her culture and how much of herself is her world and how much of herself is her ego and how much of herself is something else seemed relevant to this discussion of Neolithic whatever. I'll look for a guest. It's very hard to find somebody who's both interesting and not a crank. All the cranks are very interesting. But we'll see.
在，你知道，梦与未知，未知与创造力之间，并利用那些让她害怕的东西在她的故事和艺术中。这和我对我的病人所做的一样。这也是我渴望与自己保持更好联系的事情。所以我猜我就说到这里。但是，你知道，在这一点上出现的很多事情，看着一个孩子观察她自己有多少是她的文化，有多少是她的世界，有多少是她的自我，有多少是其他的东西，似乎与这次关于新石器时代什么的讨论有关。我会寻找一位嘉宾。很难找到一个既有趣又不是怪人的人。所有的怪人都非常有趣。但我们会看看。
Thanks for listening, guys. I hope there's something interesting here. A little bit more gradual information on the blog article. And I'll talk to you soon. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢大家的收听。希望这里有一些有趣的内容。博客文章中有更多渐进的信息。我们很快再聊。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。